on cbs's Face the Nation this weekend
they talked to Chicago Democrat voters
and they discussed well what's going on
with the Democrats because you know in
Chicago we'll find out how many people
got shot in Chicago this weekend can we
do that while we throw to this clip uh
so here is video of this is just a
random woman they went to find Democrats
in Chicago her name is lashon uh and uh
she's not happy with Democrats in
Chicago lashon I'd like to get you to
weigh in on this I can also agree with
some of his points
um I really would say sex education I
feel like um some things you know are
brought to the children's attention they
wouldn't even think about and you have
eight kids I imagine you have some
pretty specific ideas in your mind when
you're speaking yes about this yes and
the children are yeah they're really
influenced you can teach them one thing
at home but when they go to school
they're just as much influenced by their
teachers and their surroundings and we
should have more input depend parents of
what we want them to learn
isn't that fascinating isn't that
fascinating just wait till Daily Beast
or huffpo or Media Matters or somebody
tries to do a hit piece on lashon a
mother of eight in Chicago who's upset
that they're teaching all this gender
craziness to her kids right she's by any
estimation I would guess this woman is
basically a lefty a Democrat right she
lives in a big city in Chicago she just
doesn't want her kids being infected
with this stuff at the public school
level but that is not what the Democrats
want people saying right so now she's
going to have to be a bad person that is
how it works we did a little research
while we were throwing a bat clip what
did you tell me 54 shot 55 sorry
55 people were shot in Chicago this
weekend 11 were killed in Chicago this
weekend Chicago Illinois which has one
of the strongest gun laws in the country
I mean that is abs absolutely insane
there will be no protests there will be
no riots you won't find out any of their
names because basically all 55 people
shot were black all 11 people killed
were black and the shooters were black
thus the media doesn't know what to do
with this if you want a little more
context on the numbers
448 shot and killed from January 1st
2022 to September 1st 2022 okay so
that's in nine months which of course is
a record